von spiele ich einmal durch du bist kein
Blut mehr in der Leitung zu sehen ist
Rike beckhöfer 25 Jahre alt
Auszubildende Berufswunsch intensiv
Krankenpflegerin
[Musik]
haben die zwei Jahre Pandemie mit ihnen
gemacht und wie geht es für sie weiter
Frühschicht für Rika beckhöfer für sie
ist es Tag eins auf der Intensivstation
der katholischen Uniklinik in Bochum im
Rahmen eines Praktikums
begleitet wird sie heute morgen von
Praxisanleiter Philipp Schellbach denn
die 25-Jährige Rica beckhöfer ist noch
in der Ausbildung ihr Berufswunsch
intensiv Krankenpflegerin und das in
Zeiten von Corona
[Musik]
mit Corona infizierten Patienten
d'africa beckhöfer jetzt noch nicht
arbeiten im März will sie ihr Examen
machen was da auf sie zukommt davon hat
sie in den drei Jahren Ausbildung schon
einen Eindruck bekommen auch was die
Schattenseiten des Berufs angeht
[Musik]
aber wie gesagt je mehr Pflegekräfte wir
werden desto weniger Personalmangel
haben wir dann im Endeffekt
haben die den gibt's die Rente
ok sie dringend Rica beckhöfer gebraucht
wird sieht man auf der nächsten Station
denn in fast jeder Schicht fehlt hier
mindestens eine Pflegekraft dieser
Patient hatte am Morgen einen
Herzinfarkt musste wiederbelebt werden
seit Jahren ist so etwas Routine für
intensiv Krankenpflegerin Anna
muschalski dann kam Corona damit begann
eine Zeit in der auch die 33-Jährige
immer mal wieder an ihre
Belastungsgrenze stieß
[Musik]
wie gestern aber auch häufig durch die
Unterbesetzung die Januar auch
allgegenwärtig ist in der Hochrhöner
Zeit wenn alle isole alle Zimmer nur
noch Isolation sind und man halt doch
wirklich Stress hat nur musst halt
gucken wie man sich selber organisieren
kann und man wird seinen eigenen
Standard nicht mehr gerecht was dann
halt doch irgendwo frustrierend ist
[Musik]
Situation WM wo man doch schlucken muss
das sind auch Patienten die im Alter
meiner Eltern sind wo ich dann doch
wirklich doch mal darüber nachdenke wie
schnell das dann aufgehen kann und dass
die Situation die haben wir halt auch
alle im Team doch irgendwo uns auch zu
Herzen genommen und
diesen Momenten gab es viele in den
letzten zwei Jahren manchmal vielleicht
zu viele
Patienten Bach kennengelernt
hat sie sehr intensiv betreut hat sich
mit ihnen über die Familie und so eine
ihren Hintergrund unterhalten und man
hat ja gesehen dass es in den
allermeisten Fällen immer und immer
schlechter geworden ist und
das so mitzuerleben natürlich auch die
Reaktion der Patientinnen mitzubekommen
die merken natürlich auch dass es den
immer schlechter geht es
schwierig die patient hatten Angst und
musste sie trotzdem wieder Distanz durch
die ISO Kittel und die Schutzkleidung
irgendwie gut betreuen und das war schon
schwer mitzuerleben wie es dem Patient
schlechter gegangen ist intubiert werden
mussten und viele halt auch hinter
verstorben sind
das muss man erst einmal verkraften und
besprechen vielleicht mit Kolleginnen
und Kollegen aber dafür war oft keine
Zeit so wurde Ausbelastung Überlastung
und die wurde zum Problem
bei mir warst du nicht das Problem dass
ich mir nur schwierig eingestehen konnte
dass ich tatsächlich das auch arbeiten
muss weil bisher hat das immer super
geklappt so habe ich ihn ein bisschen
meinen Kollegen drüber gesprochen meine
Freundin beim Partner und dann war es
gut und dann zu merken PNG reicht es
nicht mehr
war für mich schwierig einzugestehen und
ich glaube bei vier meiner Kolleginnen
auch
ihren Job hat sie gekündigt eine
Rückkehr in die Pflege kommt für Luisa
Haas unter den derzeitigen Bedingungen
nicht infrage und damit ist sie nicht
allein
ganz konkret geht mit mir gemeinsam eine
Dezember eine andere Kollegin noch und
Ende Januar noch zwei weitere von denen
ich weiß und ich glaube es sind nicht
die letzten die gehen
szalski will bleiben
Corona fordert sie heraus aber noch hält
sie durch
ich mag den Job ich mochte ihn schon
immer ich mag die Herausforderung hier
ich finde super spannend den Bereich ist
jeder Tag ist anders ich kann diese
Situation ändern sich so schnell ich mag
gerne im Team zu arbeiten gerade mein
Team ist mir sehr wichtig
Auszubildende Rica beckhöfer hat ein
Ziel intensiv Krankenpflegerin ist ihr
Traumberuf das ist dabei nicht immer
leicht sein wird das weiß sie
[Musik]